[Music]
on June 30th
get ready we've been waiting for the
blink out event of the summer
we're going back to villainy Despicable
Me 3
[Music]
[Music]
how could you let Balthazar brats just
get away you're fired
he's really good to snuggle with I miss
what are you doing since you don't have
a job I just wanted to help
ah excuse me oh hey could you oh of
course
now as I was saying hi good my seriously
oh I really must have a word with you on
behalf of your twin brother drew why
twin brother hey brother
I can't doesn't love this guy look at
him of his hair would make you better
look at this face I'm so mad you must
see the beautiful wife oh sweet talker
this place is amazing it's nice like
gasps you're I'm not really into things
Masek room you losing blood Hey koukin
boobs you ready to continue the family
tradition
you and me no I left that life behind me
just one
[Music]
I'm going in
[Music]
haha okay
this does not mean that you're going
back to being valence
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]